[Music]
on this saturday night devastation and
celebration as abortion clinics start
shutting down in some u.s states
the places where doctors can now face
jail time
our jackson proskow is in a state with
one of the most restrictive bands in
america camping out to fly out i've been
trying to get this passport since
february ottawa's plan to shorten
winding passport lines and irritating
delays another shortage caused by the
pandemic unfortunately about a week
before the lessons were supposed to
happen it was canceled because they
didn't have lifeguards the ripple down
of cancelled life guarding courses and
what it means for the summer ahead from
timmins to the moon it sounds crazy
until someone's clever enough to make it
happen a canadian startup's surprising
new way to get to space for less
global national with bara nasser
good evening to you thank you so much
for joining us tonight
tensions are high 24 hours after the
overturning of roe v wade as america
takes stock
[Applause]
[Music]
protests are turning hostile in some u.s
cities as demonstrations carry on into
the second day and in some places the
supreme court decision is having
immediate implications abortion clinics
are shutting their doors and in states
where it's illegal to terminate a
pregnancy doctors who disobey could face
years in prison jennifer johnson starts
us off tonight at the epicenter of the
historic decision in washington
from coast to coast angry protests after
the supreme court's expected but still
shocking decision to overturn roe v wade
which has guaranteed a woman's right to
abortion for the past 50 years
my first reaction is furious what it
means that now legally the status of
women in america is breeder and
incubator i'm going to give you a
doctor's name generations of women
thought this day would never come that
an established law for half a century
would never be overturned it was
devastating news for elizabeth kiefer
krauss who had to make the excruciating
decision to have two late-term abortions
to save her own life and there are about
26 000 of us every year
who are in situations like mine after
the high court's decision 26 states will
soon make abortions illegal or severely
restrict them last year over 300
thousand abortions were performed in
those states already arkansas state
leaders have taken action restoring to
the state of arkansas the authority to
prohibit abortion anyone caught
performing an abortion in arkansas now
faces 10 years in prison in wisconsin
planned parenthood immediately stopped
performing abortions the medical
director had to break the news to
patients in the waiting room
today i had to look people in the eye
and turn them away
when they were seeking abortions in at
least eight states abortions will be
illegal even in cases of rape and incest
women will now be forced to travel to
other states to get an abortion but that
will be costly situations may become
dire for many it's
poor women it's black women it's
immigrant women who are going to be most
affected by this because they are the
ones who do not have the resources to
travel three states away where abortion
might be legal anti-abortion activists
are vowing to try even harder to stop
these women from traveling to other
states to obtain abortions
we are going to have to just push even
harder than we have been to encourage
women to let their baby live and to seek
out the resources that are available
president joe biden is already promising
to protect access to fda approved
abortion pills but passing a federal law
in congress guaranteeing a woman's right
to abortion has no chance of getting
through the divided senate
why women now say their voices have to
be heard at the ballot box come november
jennifer johnson global news washington
13 u.s states have so-called trigger
bans in which an abortion ban would or
could automatically take effect in the
absence of roe v wade one of those
states is tennessee where the law there
empowers the state to enact a near total
abortion ban within 30 days at the u.s
supreme court overturning the ruling
with more we find our jackson prosco in
nashville tonight jackson
pharah tennessee will soon have some of
the most restrictive abortion laws in
the u.s and there's now a rush to bring
them into effect as quickly as possible
the decision from the supreme court
triggered a 30-day countdown in the
state on a full abortion ban with no
exceptions for cases of rape or incest
but more immediately the state is seeing
whether the courts will lift an existing
stay on the heartbeat bill the state
passed in 2020 that banned abortion
after six weeks that bill was blocked by
the courts at the time if the stay is
lifted the effect will be almost
immediate now as you can imagine women
in the state are deeply worried about
what this means for them tennessee
already ranks 41st out of the 50 states
for the health of women and children and
black women in particular are three
times more likely to die from
pregnancy-related complications than
white women this is definitely another
way to keep people down like in poverty
if we have a kid you know that takes so
much of our time you have to call off
work you can't get paid you know they
don't pay for uh leave of absence if you
have a child anything like that
the us doesn't do that i feel it is a
war on women you know it's we're losing
our rights as we speak it's very
upsetting
and frustrating now staff at the local
planned parenthood clinic tell me they
plan to reopen for business as usual on
monday and they will continue providing
abortions until they're told they no
longer can but understanding that the
clock is ticking they say their focus
will shift to helping women in tennessee
travel out of state to receive care
farah
jackson proskow in nashville for us this
evening thank you jackson
u.s president joe biden has signed the
most sweeping gun violence bill in
decades into law the bipartisan
legislation toughens background checks
for young gun buyers it also provides
funding for mental health services and
closes the so-called boyfriend loophole
by keeping guns away from dating
partners convicted of abuse however it
does not ban assault weapons or require
background checks for all gun purchases
well this bill doesn't do everything i
want
it does include actions i've long called
for that are going to save lives
biden signed the 13 billion bill just
before leaving washington for the g7
summit in germany
for months backlogs at airports and
passport and immigration processing
delays has made travel that much more
frustrating for canadians well now the
prime minister has set up a special task
force to help with the problem with a
new sense of urgency
abigail beeman looks at the state of
passport delays in this country and why
the union says
it was all avoidable
from trying to keep warm you take an
extra one just in case to beating the
heat canadians across the country have
been camping out or sticking it out at
passport offices these seniors couldn't
believe the scene in surrey bc and took
it upon themselves to hand out water
shame on this country shame on this
government shame the stories of wait
times seem unbelievable i've been
sleeping here every day during the week
so this is night number three for me
of all night at a passport place and
some are dire my mother-in-law is in
hospital she's not doing well so we need
to go and see her urgently i certainly
believe the problem was predictable and
avoidable the head of the union
representing passport officers says
they've been warning the government of
problems since last year the first
10-year renewal passports were issued in
2013 and with some countries requiring
at least six months until expiry they
wanted the government to prepare for a
run on applications in 2022 plus add in
the easing of travel restrictions now
massive backlogs and weights have led to
some scary situations employees swarmed
or followed to their vehicles we've had
employees spat in offices we've had
employees
push
screamed at psychologically
harassed labor shortage a major issue
not helped by those conditions the
government has committed to hiring
hundreds of new staff training takes 12
to 15 weeks promising the first cohort
will be ready to work next week i think
people are fed up with excuses there
shouldn't be any
there should be a reality the
realization that we need to move faster
minister mark miller co-chairs a new
task force announced saturday trying to
improve access to government services
including passports airport wait times
and immigration backlogs he says the 10
ministers will meet early next week and
work through the summer to find both
short medium and long-term solutions
canadians do not deserve this type of
service from their government and they
have every right to be mad as hell about
it how fast they find those solutions
remains to be seen
abigail beeman global news ottawa
and the prime minister is currently on
his way to germany for a key meeting of
g7 leaders but he started his day in
rwanda finishing up his work at the
commonwealth heads of government summit
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken reports the topic at hand
for all of these meetings
global food insecurity
we need you to be the leaders you are
today prime minister justin trudeau
started his final day at the
commonwealth summit encouraging young
people to get involved in politics but
he and the other prime ministers and
presidents at this summit spent much
time talking about the global food
crisis they say is caused by russia they
actually deliberately and specifically
targeted grain storage facilities
to destroy
ukrainian grain
they've been stealing grain
they have been worsening
the food crisis across the global south
in berlin friday canada the us and 40
other countries held a pre-g7 conference
to address the world food shortage so
the combination that we've seen of covet
of climate and now conflict
is creating an even greater crisis of
food and security to help canada
announced here in rwanda it will provide
the un's world food program with 250
million dollars and at the berlin
conference international development
minister harjit sajin announced an
additional five million dollars to help
with food shortages specifically in
sub-saharan africa and we're working on
plans for more
it is far too easy to forget that food
insecurity does not impact everyone the
same it is the poorest the hardest
meanwhile russian president vladimir
putin on friday told leaders from china
india south africa and elsewhere that it
was the economic policies of the west of
the very leaders about to meet in
germany that is to blame for the food
crisis in fact russian cruise missiles
have targeted grain silos at ukraine
ports we have seen time and time again
that russia and specifically vladimir
putin
lie
they are currently
blockading
the port of odessa now trudeau did not
specify what new measures canada could
employ to help find more food to feed
the world but his official said that
back in ottawa several government
departments are trying to figure out
ways to help and it could include
everything from technology transfer to
sending canadian rail and port workers
abroad almost certainly it will involve
sending more money farah
all right that's david aiken in kigali
rwanda thank you david
thousands of norwegians took to the
streets of oslo today just hours after
two people were killed in a deadly
shooting rampage during pride
celebrations
they marched in a show of solidarity and
defiance after the oslo pride parade was
canceled over security concerns early
this morning two people were killed and
more than 20 others wounded when a
gunman opened fire inside and near a
popular lgbtq bar a 42 year old man has
been arrested and charged with terrorism
norway has since raised its terror alert
level to its highest level
coming up with the world in a fragile
state is canada's army ready concerns
from our country's top soldier
plus a swimming teacher shortage why the
next generation of lifeguards haven't
been trained yet
next week prime minister justin trudeau
will head to madrid for the 2022 nato
summit now he's expected to show off
canada's new defense spending but it may
not be all it's cracked up to be or even
that new our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson sat down with
canada's chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer on this week's
edition of the west block mercedes
farah canada's top soldier is worried
about global security saying we are
entering an unprecedented time of
potential conflict and the canadian
armed forces need the funds to be able
to fight
but a recent government pledge made
amidst fighter jet fanfare to pour 4.9
billion dollars into continental defense
may not be all that it appeared to be
defense sources say the money may not be
new but rather recycled from within
existing department of national defense
programs and that's leading to fear of
possible cuts
canada's top soldier says there has been
no discussion of cuts at this time but
even he wasn't sure where the supposedly
new money is coming from i haven't
completely figured out myself this the
source of funds for this so i can't i
can't say definitive definitively where
it's coming from you know i will say
though the announcement was welcome
recycled money would obviously be very
different than an injection of all new
billions of dollars and will raise
questions about canada's commitment to
defense spending which already falls
well short of the two percent nato
benchmark that's what the u.s and others
have been pressing canada to reach the
minister of national defense's office
said they would provide a statement to
global news but did not return a request
for comment by deadline about where the
money was coming from and there's no
question the canadian armed forces need
money in an increasingly dangerous world
general air warns the global order may
be at a turning point more fragile than
it's been in generations we've seen
signs of that unraveling russia's
invasion of ukraine is now in its fourth
month meanwhile chinese fighter jets
have been aggressively buzzing canadian
and australian aircraft in international
airspace air says canadians should brace
for more confrontation between liberal
democracies like canada on one hand and
authoritarian regimes on the other over
the course of the last number of weeks
i've i've traveled
and have had
numerous conversations with my my
counterparts chiefs of defense in in our
closest allies in europe um in asia
pacific and they are all very concerned
the threat of uh global conflict of
great power conflict as is is as great
as it has been in decades uh so it uh we
need to be worried we'll have more on
that and how the military is trying to
deal with sexual misconduct ahead on the
show tomorrow farah
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thank you mercedes and you can watch
mercedes full interview with canada's
chief of the defense staff tomorrow on
the west block right here on global
ahead another pandemic pitfall why
lifeguards are in short supply this
summer season
watching global national
kids looking to cool off this summer at
the beach or pool may face
disappointment as the country grapples
with a major lifeguard shortage swim
instructors have also become hard to
come by and it is all a byproduct of the
pandemic and as heather york's west
explains with pools open again and kids
eager to learn swimming skills
municipalities are scrambling to cope
after a long cold winter brook duvall is
looking forward to spending a summer
with her kids in the water but making
sure her children have the swimming
skills they need has not been easy
through the pandemic was tough because
there were
lessons started and then cancelled
and then for the most part there weren't
lessons at all then when the duvals
finally found lessons this spring
unfortunately about a week before the
lessons were supposed to happen it was
canceled because they didn't have
lifeguards the city of toronto says it's
had to cancel about 15 percent of its
summer swim programs because of staffing
in calgary that number is 55 percent but
the problem extends nationwide it really
stemmed from the
the pandemic two years ago when
everything shut down in march of 2020
many lifeguards and swim instructors
were furloughed or lost their jobs
and not everyone has come back the
shutdown has also meant the next
generation of lifeguards who would
usually be preparing for the role in
their early teens haven't been able to
access the necessary courses
across the country communities have had
to reduce pool hours and swim programs i
think it's going to take time for us to
get back to our pre-pandemic service
level you know over the next year we're
going to work diligently at it
the tight labor market has meant many
municipalities have had to get creative
west vancouver found success recruiting
uncertified candidates early in the
season the selected candidates were then
offered the opportunity to have free
training and we would put them through
their nl their national lifeguard and
their wsi which is their water safety
instructor we are now predicting that
we'll be fully staffed by the middle of
july
back in toronto duvall is hopeful for
better luck finding lessons this fall
planning to teach her boys some skills
herself over the summer as they spend as
much time as they can at the pool
heather urex west global news calgary
next what if it didn't cost a lot to get
to space a canadian startup competing
with spacex to send cargo to the moon
the term space race became popular
during the cold war as the u.s and
russia competed to be the first to put
an astronaut on the moon
well today the race is no longer just
between two countries space is rapidly
becoming more accessible to developing
nations and companies right now the only
way to get to outer space is to launch
an extremely expensive and
environmentally damaging rocket but
what if there was a cheaper more
eco-friendly way mike drillet reports
there's only ever been one way to launch
a rocket
brute force earth's atmosphere is just
too dense to do it any other way enter
space ride a canadian startup which aims
to launch its rockets from high altitude
balloons when you think of rocket
manufacturing the mine goes to cape
canaveral florida houston star city
russia certainly not here unit 12 of
this nondescript office complex
in concord ontario
but technology has clearly evolved so
here we are canada's first rocket
factory we are building
an on-demand
affordable and frequent access to outer
space
near and far
now that might be a bit confusing a bit
let's break it down a balloon will carry
space ride's rocket three times higher
than commercial airlines fly from there
microcomputers determine the rocket's
trajectory before it launches into the
atmosphere
unlike commercial tourist rockets space
ride won't be transporting people it's
only for
package delivery and by package it could
be satellites it could be a tool to fix
something in space and what makes them
unique is the ability to launch on short
notice it costs upwards of a million
dollars to reserve a spot on spacex's
rockets space ride will transport the
same amount of equipment for 250 000 the
first launch from timmins ontario is
planned for next year and then in 2024
they hope to transport a satellite to
orbit the moon it sounds crazy until
someone's clever enough to make it
happen and everybody goes oh yeah we
always needed that we just never could
do it before it's an uber-like service
for space
put another way it's an elegant solution
to a brute force problem mike trelay
global news toronto
canadian ingenuity at its best that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm pharyn asser and on behalf of our
whole crew i want to thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight tonight's your canada is
killarney ontario we love seeing your
canada so please keep emailing us those
photos the address is viewers at
globalnational.com
until i see you tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other have a great
saturday night
[Music]
[Music]
you